you can feel the energy innovation
Silicon Valley design thinking globally
recognized experts
it's truly diverse crew a new way of
thinking that I can take back to our
corporation
part of the issue that managers face is
that the world changes that's changing
so rapidly that the folks who are
actually doing the managing don't have
time to sort of sit back and think how
might I do this better we become very
biased in our decision-making in our
assessments based on the environment we
live in and so it's incredibly important
to step back to step out of that comfort
area your different perspectives here
are different ideas and do a check on
what do I really know versus what I
think I know
there is an atmosphere here that fosters
innovation creativity and allows you to
get focused and really concentrated in
the learning and in sharing experiences
with the friends every day I see people
thinking about new ways to do things how
do we serve customers how do we make
money how do we make sure we create a
great culture and so the ability in a
very intense period of time for you
really are able to share best practices
and build a great network of people
around the world
[Music]
my research largely focuses on
collective action how to get groups of
people together
do you know wait to undertake large
changes how do i scale my top management
team well actually how do you change a
successful company very hard to do the
warmth that is provided from the
Stanford professors is really endearing
[Music]
in my gonnago she ation class I talk
first about the negotiation process
itself beyond an adversarial win-lose
kind of dynamic to try to get them to
think about not only value creation but
value claiming I have teams in five
different countries and seeing the
different people and their attitude
towards negotiations was very important
for me
[Music]
every time you think you cracked the
case or you are on top of the issue you
see another brilliant or different or
surprising point of view I once had an
executor say to me this is a really
interesting idea you have but I could
never take the time to do this and my
response was because you're so time
stressed you actually need to be able to
do this you have to stop and ask
yourself are you really always at the
top of your game having that opportunity
to step aside and think about things
differently we get so entrenched in our
everyday work it's hard we're just
trying to keep the game going and this
allows you the chance to step back and
say is there a different way of playing
the game and there is
[Music]